[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 152
at the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
My name is Mark Mandel,
and as always, I'm
here with my colleague,
Melanie Warrick.
Hey there, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hello!
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
MELANIE WARRICK: We're
in the same room.
MARK MANDEL: We are
MELANIE WARRICK: I
don't know when's
the last time we were
actually in the same room.
MARK MANDEL: Probably about
three or four weeks ago.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
was a long time ago.
MARK MANDEL: It was.
Pretty excited this week.
You're bringing yet another
one of your amazing episodes
or interviews that you had
while you were in Africa.
MELANIE WARRICK: I am.
This is our last interview,
actually, that we captured
while I was over in Cape Town--
specifically, Stellenbosch--
at the Deep Learning Indaba.
And we specifically met
with Karim and Muthoni, who
both are out of InstaDeep,
and they talked to us
a little bit about
their corporation,
as well as just, in general,
AI corporations out of Africa,
and communities that are
being built, because Muthoni,
in particular, has a community
that she's established out
of Nairobi.
So we get into that,
which will be great.
But as always, we start out with
our cool things of the week,
and we're going to end with
our question of the week.
And the question, which is
coming all the way from Mark,
which is, if I want to create
a GKE cluster with a specific
major Kubernetes version--
or even just the latest--
using the command line
tools, how do I do that?
MARK MANDEL: How do you do that?
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
I don't know.
But hopefully, you know, so that
you can tell me how we do that.
All right.
So, cool things of the week.
We're going to kick it off
with an article we both found.
And this was
actually Mark found.
And this is this
article that's titled,
"Is There Life on Other Planets?
Google Cloud Is Working with
NASA's Frontier Development Lab
to Find Out."
So it's really
interesting, actually.
It talks a little bit
about these two approaches
that they've broken down into
researching the biologies
of distant planets.
And one approach is,
in particular, they're
modeling the possible
atmospheres that
could exist on distant planets.
And they analyzed more than
270,000 simulated atmospheres
on Compute Engine.
And this modeling that
they did, they actually
have code that they've
shared on GitHub.
It's called PyAtmos.
And there's a link in the blog
post that you can check out.
And then the second approach
is that they're then
generating an
actual spectral data
set of over 3 million rocky
terrestrial exoplanets
with machine learning.
So apparently we don't
have enough data yet,
but we have a ton
of visual images
that have been captured by
different satellites that
exist, and then they've
done a significant amount
of simulating as well, to try
to help come up with good models
to identify rocky terrains that
would potentially have life.
So that data set,
they're planning
to release sometime
in the near future,
and you can keep
an eye out for it.
But you should
check this blog out.
It's interesting.
And just hearing about what's
going on in that space,
and how machine learning
technology is playing a role.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
In my next cool
thing of the week,
combines actually both of us,
games and AI, which I think
is really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's special.
MARK MANDEL: It is special.
One of the community members--
and I'm going to apologize.
I'm going to mess up your name.
I'm going to assume it's
[INAUDIBLE],, is probably close.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good job.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
going to go with that.
They are a data scientist.
They've been doing amazing
stuff with the "StarCraft II"
Learning Environment project.
So if you're not
familiar with that,
that's a project that
comes out of DeepMind.
PySC2 is DeepMind's
Python component
of the "StarCraft II" Learning
Environment, basically.
It exposes Blizzard
Entertainment's
"StarCraft II's"
machine learning
API a Python environment.
Basically, you can
build intelligent agents
that play "StarCraft II,"
which is kind of awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's all
part of this effort that's
going on right now, like
DeepMind's had worked
on AlphaGo, and that's part
of their space, "Dota 2," out
of open AI, exploring
reinforcement learning
algorithms in the
machine learning space
to be able to play these games
and have the machines play
these better than
humans, in essence.
But this is a place you
can experiment with,
and tools you can
experiment with.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah.
The cool thing of
the week is not just
that, because that is cool,
but the thing that [INAUDIBLE]
has actually done is, if you
listen to this and you're like,
that sounds great, I
want to play with it,
they wrote a Codelab
that you can go through
to learn about the
environment, how to set it up,
how to get it
going, and basically
start building and running
your own agents, which
is super cool.
It's really cool as
well in that-- well, you
do need "StarCraft," the game,
but you don't need a license
to actually set it up and
run it, which is really nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like how
I'm able to get you over
to the machine learning
side with the games.
Another cool thing of the
week we want to mention
is there's an
additional module that
has been added to the machine
learning crash course that's
out there.
And this module in
particular, it's
focused on fairness
and machine learning.
So you should check this out if
you have any interest in this.
I brought this up, I
know, a lot this year,
and we did a podcast a
while back about machine
learning bias and fairness.
And so this is a nice module
that helps you explore that,
and looking at different
types of human biases
that can manifest
in training data.
And it helps provide strategies
to identify them and evaluate
their effect, so you can see
that in the machine learning
crash course.
Check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Awesome.
We have one of our
wonderful developer advocate
teammates, Martin Omander.
They have written a server list
from the ground up building
a simple microservice
with Cloud Functions.
This is part one, apparently.
They take a real-world approach
of coming up with a company
that needs to do a certain
thing-- in this case,
listing and viewing docs--
and then taking
that and saying, OK,
how can we do that
with Cloud Functions?
What would that flow look like?
How would that work with,
say, in between talking
to different teammates and
how they would work together
on this?
It's actually a really nice
step-by-step instructional
on how to build up these
sort of microservices.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And also, last thing
in the cool thing of the
week is that, while I
was at Deep Learning Indaba,
I met Emily Muller and Rebone
Meraba, who are building
out their own podcast called
"Superposition."
And they did this
recording with Omoju Miller
and Nando de Freitas, who
talked about machine learning,
talked about the conference.
It's a great podcast, and a
great video that they included.
So we're going to include
a link and give them
a shout-out in our
podcast for this week.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Seems appropriate,
considering we're also talking
about deep learning this week.
All right, Mark.
I think it's time for us
to get into our interview.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
On today's podcast,
I'm excited that Karim Beguir
and Muthoni Wanyoike are
both joining me to
talk about InstaDeep
and building
communities in Africa.
So thank you both for joining.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: Thank
you for having us.
KARIM BEGUIR: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: We are actually
recording this as another one
of our podcasts that we're
currently recording out
of the Deep Learning Indaba,
which is currently happening
in Stellenbosch, South Africa.
So let me go ahead and get
started like we usually
do, which is, Karim,
can you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
KARIM BEGUIR: Sure.
So I'm half Tunisian,
half French.
I actually grew up in a small
city close to the Sahara
called Tataouine, like the
sand planet in "Star Wars."
MELANIE WARRICK: I was
about to say, "Star Wars!"
KARIM BEGUIR: Exactly.
And literally, I grew
up through learning,
progressively made
my way to graduate
to a call polytechnic in
France, and ultimately, the US,
where I was at the Courant
Institute at New York
University.
And through the
process, I always
had this idea to give back.
Come back to Africa
at some point
to do something
interesting and useful.
And this has guided my choices
into what is today InstaDeep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Muthoni, tell us
a bit about you.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE:
Yeah, thank you.
I grew up in a small town
in Kenya called Nyahururu.
And after that, went
to school in Nyeri,
and then started working
in the city, Nairobi.
I work at InstaDeep.
I lead the team in
Nairobi, as well as
a strategy of
expanding into Africa
and building talent
across Africa.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
OK, so as I mentioned, this
is being currently recorded
at the Deep Learning Indaba.
I know we're not going to
be releasing it exactly
at the same time,
but what has been
really valuable experiences
for you from this conference
so far?
KARIM BEGUIR: I think the level
of enthusiasm is fantastic.
The quality of the speakers
is really top notch.
I like to see this as a NIPS.
The same quality and
speakers that you
would have at NIPS,
except that NIPS
has 5,000 or 6,000
attendees, and here, it's
a much smaller audience.
So I think it's an
exceptional opportunity
to really build AI
communities in Africa,
and we should be very thankful
to the Deep Learning Indaba
team for what they are
doing, and the changes they
are making on the ground.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And Muthoni, what are some
of the valuable experiences
for you?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE:
For me, I think
having been part of planning
the Indaba this year,
the main takeover
for me has just
been to see all the people
that we've been communicating
with for many months
come together,
and to also see the quality
of research that is coming out
of Africa, and very interesting
posters are being presented
every day, as well as
very interesting sessions.
For example, to build on
machine learning skills,
or how to write
good paper skills,
and that kind of experience
has been really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Muthoni, I know you are involved
with actually putting together
this conference.
How did you get involved?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: It's
a very interesting.
So my colleague, my co-organizer
of the community in Nairobi
came to the Indaba last year,
and the planning committee
had already decided
that they wanted to host
the Indaba in Kenya in 2019.
When she came to me and shared
the vision of the Indaba, which
is to strengthen the
participation of Africans
in machine learning, I
was sold immediately,
because it's what we do with
the community in Nairobi.
So then we had a
chat with Shakir,
and the rest of the team.
We seemed to like
each other, and we
started the process of
planning the Indaba this year.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
the rest is history.
Now you're in, and you're
never going to leave.
KARIM BEGUIR: Yes, and we'll be
hosting 1,000 people next year,
so that should be exciting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh,
that's really exciting.
Karim, you're here this year
because you're speaking.
Can you tell us a
little bit about what
you're talking about?
KARIM BEGUIR: Yeah.
So my session's going to be
on Thursday about the life
of a machine learning startup.
And the goal is really
to give some insights
about what it takes to build
a startup, but specifically,
a machine learning startup,
and specifically, in Africa.
So looking forward to
share some knowledge,
and also raise the
awareness in the AI
community about
the opportunities
that there are for AI in Africa.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are
some of the opportunities?
KARIM BEGUIR: I think we
have tremendous talent.
And one of the insights
that I want to convey
is that, in today's
world, it's actually
possible to build a
high-quality machine learning
startup in Africa.
All the sources of
knowledge are there.
The sources of
high-quality mentoring
are there now, with events
such as Deep Learning Indaba.
So really make
the new generation
aware of what's possible, and
share some of the enthusiasm
and some of the
experience that we've
been through at InstaDeep.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
tell us a little bit
about what InstaDeep
does, how it started.
KARIM BEGUIR: So InstaDeep
is an AI startup.
It's an African AI
startup which bridges
the gap between advanced AI
research and large companies
that have real business needs.
So the way we've done that is
by developing our own research,
but being able to explain and
convey to the communities,
to the companies, how advanced
AI can benefit to them.
So that has been our experience.
And what we've discovered
by doing that-- also,
the project started in
North Africa, in Tunisia.
Started as a
bootstrap, literally.
My co-founder Zora and I
started with two laptops
and a lot of enthusiasm.
And what we've discovered
is that it's actually
possible to bring
promising African talent
to competitive levels in AI.
To be able to add real values to
companies in Africa and beyond.
That's the main takeaway, and
that's also my main message.
We have to be optimistic
about AI in Africa.
The opportunity is tremendous.
And I think this is our agenda.
All here to convey
that message, and make
sure it's widely spread.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's definitely
not a hidden agenda, for sure.
Well, in terms of InstaDeep,
when we were talking offline,
you were telling me that it's
in five different locations.
KARIM BEGUIR: Exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
where are those locations?
KARIM BEGUIR: So we
started initially in Tunis.
In Africa, now we
have three locations.
We're operational in Kenya.
That's the team
that Muthoni leads.
We are also operational
in Lagos, Nigeria.
And we also have offices
in Paris and London.
So five locations,
and looking forward to
continue to expand our
presence in Africa.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And Muthoni, how did
you get involved?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: Through
my community work.
Karim had visited Nairobi
because he's a Google Launchpad
Accelerator mentor.
So Nairobi is quite
the city, and you just
fall in love immediately.
So he was interested in
setting up in Nairobi,
and was meeting with people
within the community.
So that's how I met
with Karim, and was
sold on his vision of
growing AI in Africa,
and providing opportunities
for a billion people
to work on exciting projects.
And yeah, the rest
is history again.
MELANIE WARRICK:
The rest is history,
and now you're working
with the group.
In terms of-- you'd mentioned
about the Google Launchpad
Accelerator.
I know you're also a GDE,
a Google Developer Expert.
I also know we
talked about this,
that you're using Google
Cloud products as well.
What are some of the products
that you're currently
using at InstaDeep?
KARIM BEGUIR: TensorFlow
is our main platform in AI.
It's a tremendously
powerful tool.
I think people do not realize
how powerful this tool is.
And we're really grateful
to have that free access
that Google has provided.
So in my experience
as also an MLGD,
I've come to appreciate all
the work that Google is doing.
Particularly, for example,
products such as the Assistant
are tremendously powerful,
and make advanced AI
available to all start-ups.
I mentioned another one, which
I think is extremely impressive.
It is Auto Machine
Learning, AutoML.
That is a
groundbreaking product.
It effectively enables
start-ups all over the world--
and including in Africa-- to
have access to high-quality AI
without needing extended teams.
So participating too,
Launchpad Accelerator Africa
with Google, helping
build the ecosystem
has been also a
tremendous opportunity
for me to meet great people.
And it's through
those channels that I
have come to meet with Muthoni.
And also being
convinced that now
is the time to make a difference
on the ground in Africa.
So it has encouraged me
and acted as a catalyst
to the vision I initially had.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And you were mentioning
about communities, Muthoni.
I do want to talk a
little bit about-- there's
a community in
particular that you run,
which is the Nairobi
Women in Machine Learning.
How did you get involved
with that community?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: The community
with Kathleen two years ago.
I had just graduated
from my undergrad
and was working in government.
The Kenya Open Data Initiative.
And there was a lot of buzzwords
around big data, AI, and all
that.
And there was a
lot of expectations
in our scope of work.
So we were learning
a lot of new skills,
but I felt the need to connect
with people who were working
in a similar space so we can
share ideas, or resources,
or just know what is happening
around the world together.
So that's how I
learned about the Women
in Machine Learning and
Data Science community,
and reached out
to them, and they
were happy to help us
get set up in Nairobi.
And then after
that, we did a call
for volunteers who are
interested in helping
build the community.
So two years later, we
run a lot of workshops,
from introductory classes on
how to use Python and R to more
advanced classes on TensorFlow
and other advanced AI concepts.
And it's very
interesting, the range
of people attending the lessons.
For example, we have
university lecturers
coming to learn Python,
or 13-year-old girl
coming to learn how to program.
So it's been a very
interesting experience,
building that
community in Nairobi.
MELANIE WARRICK: How large
is the community right now?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: We have close
to 1,800 people on meet-up.
We probably have met
700 of the people.
So it's a huge group.
And how we run things is
that it's very volunteer-led.
So a lot of people
will come to us
and then see a need
in the community,
and we let them champion that as
a project within the community.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: Yeah.
One interesting one
that I would mention
is, we did a master class
celebrating the International
Women's in March.
We did a master class
introduction in Python and R.
And the ladies attending were
very, very interested in it.
And two of them volunteered
to grow that class,
and now they are doing a
course across four months,
and have a class of about 30
ladies in Nairobi and in Kenya
doing their course by
themselves remotely,
and then giving feedback
every week, and results,
and sharing
knowledge and skills.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What did they use
to help work remotely together?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE:
They use Slack.
So they coordinate
class and Slack.
We took the "R for Data Science"
workbook by Hadley Wickham,
and then divided that across,
and made that a curriculum
spread out over four months.
And then we use Slack to
coordinate work, as well
as GitHub, because
a lot of the people
also were not using
GitHub, and that
really counts when you're, for
example, applying for a job.
So now, they can upload
their projects there,
and they're able to showcase
their work when dealing
with recruiters, for example.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I'm pretty impressed
at how important
GitHub has become in the space.
And when I talk to
people, and I tell
them all the time--
and even here,
I was talking to people
about how important it
is to publish in GitHub.
To not wait for
it to be perfect.
To just get it out there,
and show that you're
working on something.
Well, so do you collaborate with
other Women in Machine Learning
communities, or other
communities in Nairobi
or outside of Nairobi?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: We do.
So for example, just out
of us having the community
in Nairobi, now we
have a community
in Lagos of women
in machine learning.
We also have worked with the few
women taking the data science
class in Uganda.
And just at the Indaba,
I've met very many ladies
who are very excited to
have similar communities
in their countries.
So very, very exciting times
for building the skills of women
in Africa for machine learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Sounded like you said
it was a meet-up,
so if people want to explore
or check out the group,
that's where they can find it.
Karim, what is community-- we
talked a little bit already
about this, but what
does that mean to you
in terms of these types of
communities, and your company,
and the interest
that you have in AI?
KARIM BEGUIR: So I think
it's very important
to help communities
understand the AI opportunity.
So a lot of what
we do is actually
trying to bring that
know-how, and helping people
focus on what really matters.
I would say, today, the problem
is not the lack of information.
This may be like an
information overflow.
So a big part of what
I do is I mentor.
And we also organize TensorFlow
meet-ups, very active.
We organize hackathon.
A month ago, I was in Lagos
organizing a hackathon.
I was really impressed
by the talent
and the passion of the young
students and engineer there.
So a big part of what we
do is raise awareness.
Break a sort of
mental idea that, oh,
you cannot be
world-class in Africa.
As an African AI startup, you
can compete with the best.
And we had really very
constructive exchanges
here at Deep Learning
Indaba with Nando Freitas,
and David Silver from DeepMind.
And their feedback was
really very positive,
and this encouraged us
to continue to share
the message all through Africa.
That AI is a real opportunity.
That you can be
world-class in AI.
All what it takes is positivity,
willingness to learn, energy,
and I believe, in the continent,
we have a lot of that.
MELANIE WARRICK: And any
advice or recommendations
for those companies
that are considering
looking at having their own
offices in parts of Africa?
KARIM BEGUIR: I think
the key thing in AI--
and in many other things--
is focusing on the people.
So, for example,
at InstaDeep, we
do not have a
specific plan that we
should be, for example,
having an office
in a particular country or city.
It is really driven by
the quality of the people.
When we feel we have
the right partners--
and we're so excited to
have Muthoni in Kenya.
We have a great machine
learning team also in Nigeria.
So when you have the right
team, the right people,
you can build.
And that's my main message.
And this is, I think,
it's particularly
relevant in Africa.
It's about investing
on the right people who
share your vision, who
share your enthusiasm.
So my message to companies
looking, potentially,
at hiring African talent
is, try to look actively
for the top talent.
And most importantly,
for the people who
have a willingness to learn.
A willingness to
challenge themselves
to get to a certain
level of competitiveness
and collaboration
within the team.
So I've been really surprised
by how quickly we've
met some of the right people.
And at the end of the day,
in AI or anything else,
it's people-driven.
MELANIE WARRICK: Very much so.
I agree.
And appreciate that
too, from the standpoint
of talking about the
community-building,
talking about the corporation,
having that opportunity
to explore these communities
and see where the talent is.
And then also giving
back, and giving back
in terms of the
training is phenomenal.
I know we talked about
this earlier already.
You were touching on some of
the tools that are being used.
When you bring in
your talent, it
sounds like you're doing some
of your own training as well,
and helping people grow.
Is that correct?
KARIM BEGUIR: Yes, absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
And so what are some
of the key skills,
in particular, that you're
trying to build out?
KARIM BEGUIR: So we believe that
it's possible to take motivated
and young student or engineer--
let's say undergrads,
or completing their
grad studies--
and get them very
quickly on to working
on AI research
problems which would
be considered like PhD-plus.
I think that's been one of
the fascinating surprises I've
had building the
company, is to see
that this is actually possible.
We had great success stories.
Some fantastic women,
students we had on the team.
InstaDeep really
believes in diversity,
and making sure everybody
has an equal opportunity.
And we've been really
surprised by success stories.
We've had interns push the
state of the art of work
that's been done
in Silicon Valley.
So this is, I believe,
an exciting time.
And the key message
I want to convey
is, do not believe
the AI opportunity is
something remote from you.
If you're truly motivated,
if you truly want to learn,
there is a way, and
there are mentors
available to help, whether me or
all the amazing people at Deep
Learning Indaba, to make that
opportunity a reality for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are
some of the resources that you
find more valuable for teaching,
and for helping others train?
Because I know we talked
about Hadley Wickham,
and how his book has helped
with some of the training
that you're working on
with the Nairobi Women
in Machine Learning.
Karim, do you have any
ones that particularly
come to mind that you
find very valuable?
KARIM BEGUIR: Yeah, absolutely.
There are a couple
of books which
we found to be tremendous
resources in practice.
The good news is that
they're for free.
All what it takes is
go and click a link
and you'll get them.
Download the PDF, print it,
and here you're in business.
So I say, one major
book if you're
interested in deep learning
is the "Deep Learning"
book by Ian Goodfellow,
Courville, and Bengio.
That is a fantastic one.
And I love to say
it's a fantastic
one, because it's a real test.
It starts really easy,
and the difficulty almost
increases exponentially
chapter by chapter.
So if you're motivated, take
the Goodfellow, and make sure
you finish it.
You'll be a long way into a
positive and successive career
in AI.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: I'd like to
mention something interesting
that motivates me at InstaDeep
in terms of growing talent.
So we also have very
experienced researchers
working at InstaDeep as
well, and they somehow
are paired with our
junior engineers.
And they're able to
work together very well.
So that really
helps our engineers
grow at a really, really fast
rate in terms of their skill.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a common challenge
too with most companies, is
having the ability to bring
in junior talent, and
having them be able to grow,
and the fact that you're
actually mentoring and setting
up that kind of relationship.
Some companies are doing that.
Not everybody, unfortunately,
is able to execute on it.
They're not doing it.
They're not executing on it.
KARIM BEGUIR: And I
think Muthoni's touching
an important point.
At InstaDeep, we make
sure that all projects
are cross-regional.
So different teams
have to collaborate.
And we've experienced
this in particular
with the teams we
have also in Europe.
We find it to be
a key component.
Everybody gets to the
same access to resources.
Everybody gets to
share and collaborate.
And we've had tremendously
interesting experiences
with this.
African talent can pick
it up really quick.
And we've had cases where,
really, the innovation is
driven from Africa, and
we're very proud of that.
MELANIE WARRICK: How so?
KARIM BEGUIR: So we've had,
for example, research projects.
I'll mention a
recent article which
published called "Rank
Rewards," which is effectively
taking the work that had
been pioneered by DeepMind,
and David Silver in particular,
around two-player games.
This is very interesting.
It's a massive breakthrough.
Actually, technically, AI
was invented by Alan Turing
to solve chess.
So you could say AlphaZero is
really like a moment in time.
And we were very excited
by those breakthroughs.
And we tried to think about, how
could this breakthrough apply
to real use cases, real
businesses, real situations,
whether it's around
transportation or logistics?
How to make those useful?
This has led us to
breakthroughs which
were pioneered in particular by
our North African team, which
got us to great
reviews, great feedback,
and ultimately, building
next-generation products
that will benefit our team,
our communities, and beyond.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
So off of that point
about working remotely--
and you had this great example
in terms of what was being
driven from Africa--
what are some of the
biggest challenges
that you've had working with
remote teams working together?
KARIM BEGUIR: I think it's
important to make sure people
communicate and collaborate.
So some of the challenges
are more practical.
For example, when we
organize an off-site,
make sure you're going
to get the visas,
because unfortunately, it's very
hard to travel around Africa.
So problems are
practical in nature.
But if you are really motivated,
you could go beyond them
and create a culture
of collaboration.
So at InstaDeep, we
really believe in that.
We make sure, at least twice
a year, the whole global team
meets in a location to exchange
and share directly, and build
up an inclusive culture.
So software is, I believe, the
way to go in Africa due to some
of the difficulties around
moving people, moving goods.
So we still struggle
sometimes with visas.
And Muthoni knows about this.
We have to fight to get her
in at our list of sites.
But in startup, like
in everything else,
it's about motivation.
If you really have
the motivation
to go beyond difficulties,
ultimately, in today's world,
you can.
And the point I want to also
make is that you're not alone.
If you're an African
machine learning startup,
you have the chance to
access to tech giants who
are there to help you to
develop the ecosystem.
And I found that to be
really transformational.
This also has guided
me towards the work
I do with Google as a
machine learning dev expert.
There are opportunities
out there,
so don't believe that
you're on your own.
You're not.
There are lots of
people who are super
excited about the
potential of the continent,
and will actually lend
a hand and help you.
That's been our experience.
And if we can do
the same and share
that feedback and that
positive feedback,
I think we've gone a long way.
MELANIE WARRICK: I see
you nodding, Muthoni.
Anything else you wanted to add?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: Now just to
agree that it's quite difficult
to move around the continent.
But it's interesting to see
the effort towards just making
things happen, because,
for me, representation
is very important.
And sometimes, just this
limit on moving-- for example,
we had colleagues who
were to attend the Indaba
and couldn't get their visas.
That means it blocks a
part of them accessing
resources and people
who would have
been key to their
next phase of life.
But with technology,
we are able to bridge
some of these problems, and it
becomes an easier way of life.
MELANIE WARRICK: I love the
fact that you're talking about,
particularly, how
all of your teams
have the same resource access.
And that that's what
you fight to achieve.
But I also very
much value the fact
that you're trying to make
sure that all these teams work
together.
I've worked with
remote teams as well,
and I feel like
I'm stronger when
I work with people who are
from different backgrounds,
different mindsets.
And it sounds like that's
a large part of what's
driving this, and also,
what you experience as well.
Correct?
KARIM BEGUIR: You have to create
a culture of inclusiveness
and empowerment.
All our teams are treated the
same no matter where they are.
We value ideas.
We value intellectual curiosity.
So we've had cases
where somebody
was supposed to
work on something
but turned out to be
brilliant at something else.
We love that kind of
positive surprises.
And if you create an
environment which is positive,
which pushes people
up and rewards
constant learning,
intellectual curiosity,
you are bound to
have good surprises.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: People's
motivation to do things cannot
be overstressed.
When people have their
own personal motivation
to work on projects, then
it just makes, for example,
even the small
challenges of maybe time,
because you're working
across different time zones.
But when you're
motivated to work
towards exciting challenges,
it makes some of those things--
you easily overlook
them, I think.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, anything else
that we didn't already
cover that you
wanted to touch on,
that you wanted to emphasize,
whether it's about InstaDeep,
about building communities,
about Deep Learning Indaba?
KARIM BEGUIR: Well,
to conclude, I
think it's really an
exciting time for Africa,
because there is a
transformative technology, AI,
which is happening, and
will continue to happen
for the foreseeable future.
And at the same
time, the resources
are progressively there to make
taking opportunities, building
your businesses, employing
people a reality.
So we're super excited
about this at InstaDeep,
and within the Deep
Learning Indaba.
It's a community of
like-minded people
who really sense
the opportunity.
So I think this is a historic
opportunity for Africa.
And we're super
excited about it.
And ultimately, it's about
building all this together.
This is the message of
Deep Learning Indaba.
We build together.
And that will make a difference.
So my message to
anybody who's listening
is, do not believe that
this is beyond you.
Be part of it.
Bottoms-up approach,
ultimately, is the way to go.
This is what will change Africa.
And all what it takes
is a bit of motivation,
a bit of curiosity, and not
being afraid to get started.
Great things will happen.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's wonderful.
And that actually
reminds me of something
I heard you say the other night.
Muthoni was saying yes.
Saying yes to things that also
things that feel like they're
impossible, or out
there beyond you.
Did you want to
add anything else?
MUTHONI WANYOIKE:
For me, my experience
has been that I like to
do personal assessment.
And sometime earlier this year,
I realized that I prefer--
my comfort zone is
lurking in the shadows,
and just doing stuff quietly
and silently, or on Twitter.
So when a friend
recommended the [INAUDIBLE],,
then for some reason, it
stirred something in my mind.
And that is how I
ended up, for example,
accepting to join InstaDeep,
because it was a challenge
that I wouldn't have
accepted a few months back,
or been part of the Indaba.
So yeah, I think I would
encourage people to say yes
to opportunities that
really, really scare them,
because sometimes, comfort
doesn't grow you as much.
So yeah.
And one last thing, we will be--
I'm very excited to host
the Indaba next year.
It's another huge,
huge challenge,
but I'm sure it's going
to be a fantastic year.
So I look forward to having
the Indaba in Kenya in 2019.
KARIM BEGUIR: And
on my side, I'm
very excited about the
next endeavor, which
I'm sure Muthoni is going to
be a big part of organizing.
And also, maybe something
else I wanted to add
is about machine
learning in Africa.
I think now is the time to
prove to the world as Africans
that we can raise, that
even companies out of Africa
can be competitive,
can stand on their feet
and basically provide the value
added that we need to make sure
our communities
and our economies
are successful in
the 21st century.
That's what we're trying
to do at InstaDeep.
And if I had a wish, it's to
see in the future successful AI
companies emerging from
Africa with the help
and collaboration
of tech partners
and all people of goodwill.
But this is what we
haven't seen yet.
And in particular,
InstaDeep, that's
what motivates me every day.
Can we prove as Africans that
we can race to the opportunity
and build something great for
all the communities and all
the partners we work with?
MELANIE WARRICK: Karim,
Muthoni, thank you very
much for coming on the podcast.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: Thank
you for having us.
KARIM BEGUIR: Thanks a lot.
MUTHONI WANYOIKE: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you
again, Karim and Muthoni,
for coming on the
podcast and talking to us
about AI, corporations,
communities, InstaDeep,
all the things.
We really appreciate it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thanks so much.
That was really,
really interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark,
question of the week?
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week.
MELANIE WARRICK: If I
want to create a GKE
cluster with a specific
major Kubernetes version--
or even just the latest--
using the command line
tools, how do I do that?
MARK MANDEL: This is
something that I've run into,
and I was exploring it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Really?
Did you run into this?
MARK MANDEL: I had no idea.
I really ran into this.
[CAR CRASH NOISE]
Right.
So GKE runs very specific
versions of Kubernetes.
So for example, 1.10
is available right now.
So if I'm running on the GKE,
I might be running 1.10.6.
And then usually,
there's a patch release.
So like -gke.6, or .7, or .4.
And those can roll
through pretty quickly.
You may be like, on one
day, two or three weeks ago,
you're running 1.10.6-gke.1.
And then if you come back a few
weeks later, or a month later,
it might be gke.4,
and the old version
might not be available anymore.
And you might have run scripts
either through the command
line-- or possibly
even Deployment Manager
as well-- that
are very specific.
They might be like, OK, yes, I
need this version 1.10.7.gke-3.
And that's not
available anymore,
and now, suddenly, all your
scripts break, and it sucks.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
And I've run into
that as well, where
I have to update the
script every time I want
to create a cluster, either with
GCloud, or Deployment Manager.
But you don't have to,
which is super nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: It's amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's amazing.
[CELEBRATORY MUSIC]
MARK MANDEL: So the
really nice thing
is you can actually specify
a general cluster version.
So say, for example, I want
to create a version just like
a 1.10.
I'm like, I don't care which
like dot version of 1.10.
Just create me a 1.10.
I can actually say, in my
initial cluster version
in Deployment Manager, or
cluster dash version in GCloud,
basically I can just
say, equals 1.10.
And it's just going to
grab the latest 1.10.
If I want a patch
release, I can say 1.10.7,
and it'll always grab
the latest one of that,
and with the -gke on the end.
Or if I just want the latest,
I can just write "latest."
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So it'll just work it out
for you behind the scenes.
It can save you a lot of
time, make your scripts
a little less brittle, and
make things a little bit easier
for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: We like easy.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
Mark, where are you going to be?
MARK MANDEL: I will be
at QCon in December.
But other than that, doing
some vacation next month.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Vacation!
[CELEBRATORY MUSIC]
MARK MANDEL: You?
MELANIE WARRICK: I
will be at [INAUDIBLE]
at the end of November,
and that's the main plan.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
That sounds good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
So real quick, before we wrap.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: I want to
just do a quick little PSA.
If you are in the
US, please vote.
We're not going to sit here
and tell you who to vote for.
I've got my own opinions.
But-- and you can check
out my Twitter feed
if you want to know my opinions.
But yeah, please vote.
If you're thinking
about it, if you're
on the fence, whatever,
please, definitely
vote this midterm election.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank
you so much for that,
and thank you for
joining me for yet
again on this week's podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]